mr president dr biden
madam vice president mr
imhof americans and
the world when day comes we ask
ourselves where can we find light in
this
never-ending shade the loss
we carry a sea we must wade we've braved
the belly of the beast
we've learned that quiet isn't always
peace
and the norms and notions of what just
is isn't always just
this and yet the dawn is hours before
we knew it somehow we do it somehow
we've
weathered and witnessed a nation
that isn't broken but simply
unfinished we the successors of a
country
in the time were a skinny black girl
descended from slaves and raised by a
single mother
can dream of becoming president
only to find herself reciting for one
and yes we are far from polished
far from pristine but that doesn't mean
we are striving to form a union that is
perfect we are striving to forge
our union with purpose to compose
a country committed to all cultures
colors characters and conditions
of man and so we lift our gazes not to
what stands
between us but what stands before
us we close the divide because we know
to put our future first
we must first put our differences aside
we
lay down our arms so we can reach out
our arms to one
another we seek harm to none and harmony
for all let the globe if nothing else
say this is true
that even as we grieved we grew that
even as we hurt
we hoped that even as we tired we tried
that we'll forever be tied together
victorious
not because we will never again know
defeat
but because we will never again sow
division scripture tells us to envision
that
everyone shall sit under their own vine
and fig
tree and no one shall make them afraid
if we're to live up to our own time then
victory won't lie in the blade but in
all the bridges we've made that
is the promise to glade the hill we
climb if only
we dare it because being american
is more than a pride we inherit it's the
past
we step into and how we repair it
we've seen a forest that would shatter
our nation
rather than share it would destroy our
country if it meant delaying
democracy and this effort very nearly
succeeded but while democracy can be
periodically delayed it can never
be permanently defeated in this truth
in this faith we trust for while we have
our eyes on the future
history has its eyes on us
this is the era of just redemption we
feared it at
its inception we did not feel prepared
to be the heirs of such a terrifying
hour but within it we found the power to
author
a new chapter to offer hope and laughter
to ourselves so
while once we asked how could we
possibly prevail over catastrophe
now we assert how could catastrophe
possibly prevail over us we will not
march
back to what was but move to what shall
be
a country that is bruised but whole
benevolent
but bold fierce and free we will not be
turned around or interrupted by
intimidation
because we know our inaction and inertia
will be the inheritance of the next
generation our blenders
become their burdens but one thing is
certain
if we merge mercy with mites
into mites with right then love
becomes our legacy and change
our children's birthright so let us
leave behind a country better than one
we were left with
every breath from my bronze pounded
chest we will raise this wounded world
into a wondrous one we will rise from
the gold-limbed hills
of the west we will rise from the wind
swept northeast where our forefathers
first
realized revolution we will rise from
the lake rim cities of the midwestern
states
we will rise from the sun baked south we
will rebuild
reconcile and recover and every known
nook
of our nation and every corner called
our country
our people diverse and beautiful will
emerge battered
and beautiful when day comes we step out
of the shade
aflame and unafraid the new dawn blooms
as we free it for there was always light
if only we're brave enough to see it if
only we're brave enough to be it